vous
la peau est plus de risques le chien du
voisin
c'est quoi le câlin ne veulent pas ton
satin
crise
m
fumel que le chien
mami est fait
on ignore
dictée par le chien
comme des moineaux à l'endroit d'une
fontaine
sont beaucoup plus joli que ce quatrième
abriel je l'aimé bien
que la chienne du chien
quoi
de bach à visiter
je sais pas
plus qu'ils viennent me dira
qu'elle même
la bouche
la poitrine tirée sans
angles celle du chien
il sent bon
des cuisines
là
ça
à
camille qui reposait sur moi
sous le coup de plusieurs celui de
benoît
jacquot
mon ami qu'un cheveu
c'est patron
quand on s'appelle de noir
demain son public les commandes du
voisin
c'est qui
aline qui caresse meyrin
m
mais dimanche
bon avant de participer
c'est pas
us qui viennent non
m
la voici qui valent cent
le chien sent bon la vie depuis
l'agent
avoir un chien chat alors la foire
internationale d'art contemporain ouvre
ses portes demain sur fond de